we have a deal which means lots of small
prints it's just starting to come
through now all of the text and let's
just have a look at what we're learning
so far it's going to take days to get
through this stuff but initially let's
have a look at their headlines and this
comes from the uk documentation so
released by danny street
uh and it shows you the main highlight
of this perhaps
uh is no tariffs or quotas on the
movement of goods tariff-free quota-free
it's not quite the same
as free trade because there are still
non-tariff barriers lots of form-filling
but nonetheless that is the big thing a
big part of this deal
uh as is this in political terms at
least uk sovereignty over our fishing
waters fishing became a big thing it
basically this means
the eu is going to reduce the quotas uh
the eu vessels can get and the uk gets
back
more of that in the coming years this
isn't the only stuff there's plenty
more including for instance the uk is
going to stay in certain eu programs
uh particularly uh scientific
collaboration through horizon but not
erasmus so student exchange
uh that won't be retained and it's also
worth
uh just underlining in a way the most
important institution that comes of this
it's called a partnership council now
remember that level playing field thing
it was all about
ensuring that the uk wouldn't be able to
reduce its regulations when it came to
the environmental labor standards well
we now know there's going to be this
partnership council which is going to
kind of adjudicate whether it is keeping
to that and whether to impose
terrorists that's going to be really
important in the next few years
i should say it's not just the uk which
has released documents we've also got
stuff
from the european commission as well and
it paints a very different picture it's
kind of interesting here it's not
talking about what the uk gains but what
it loses so
the free movement of persons will end
the free movement of goods
will end services too and if you flick
through this
it is just striking how much of a
different picture
it paints so for instance just skimming
through here one thing the city wanted
to retain or wanted to get was some sort
of agreement financial equivalence so
that they could do more trading in the
eu
that hasn't come through and eu
underlining passporting
rights for financial services don't
survive in this deal
and have a look at this this document
was designed i suppose to try to
discourage
other eu members from leaving showing
you on the right-hand side all those
ticks what you get in the eu
and on the left-hand side all those
crosses what you get with this new deal
what the uk
gets basically a lot of crosses on
various different things like pet
passports or indeed visa flee free
travel beyond
90 days but put it all together and what
do we have economically well let's just
kind of have a look
at this kind of assessment from the obr
the office budget responsibility now
that flat line is basically the
equivalent of if we had stayed
inside the eu now with a deal that's
kind of where we are at the moment
with a deal you would be talking
according to the obr about potentially
an economy that was four percent
smaller in the long run compare that to
no deal about six percent
smaller so clearly we're in a better
position but the key thing really is the
gap
between those two lines and staying
inside the eu is far bigger
than between a free trade deal and no
deal so everyone's relieved but
nonetheless it will potentially
according to economists
mean a smaller economy in the future